es spricht einiges dafür in deutschland
genauer an der grenze zu tschechien
steht ein landstrich wohl kurz vor einem
vulkanausbruch so geologen jedenfalls
sprechen die schwarmbeben dort dafür
dass ich etwas unter der erde tut und es
gibt noch einige indizien jetzt in
kriegs und science fiction bei uns
gibt's täglich solche spannenden themen
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen
ein vulkan in deutschland ja und das ist
gar nicht mal so abwegig die eifel ist
zum beispiel ein aktives vulkangebiet
jedenfalls für geologen auch hier
steigen zurzeit die aktivitäten unter
dem mittelgebirge der lara sie ist ein
vulkan der erst vor 11.000 jahren
ausgebrochen ist für geologen quasi erst
vor kurzem zitat wir haben im untergrund
eine veränderung die aus dem mantel
kommt und die zu einer magma bildung
führen kann
es sei eine frage der zeit waren hier
genug magma angereichert ist das dann
den vulkan speist und einen neuen
ausbruch auslöst so der essener geologie
professor ulrich schreiber unter dem
vulkankrater liegt eine magmakammer und
das kann noch hunderte von jahren dauern
oder auch unvorhersehbar stellt wir
sollten gewappnet sein
schätz geologe schreiber ob sie und das
ganze ist auch messbar forschungsteams
beobachten seismische ereignisse
gasaktivitäten oder bodenbewegungen zum
beispiel co2 austritt im lara see also
gasbläschen im wasser es gebe hohe
ausgaben und rohrrahmen werte dort sagt
schreiber in bad ems komme co2 aus der
tiefe und durch das wasser der lahn
sieht man das aufsteigen und es gibt
sogar leichte erdbeben die darauf
hindeuten dass sich die magma kammer
unter dem see füllt im jahr 2016 wurden
im bereich der osteifel 42 natürlich
erdbeben gemessen
wow was aber gar nichts gegen das
vogtland ist hier im dreiländereck von
bayern sachsen und tschechien gab es im
früher 1000 beben sogenannten
schwarmbeben jedes zehnte davon konnten
auch die bewohner dort spüren 100 also
wow und es ist tatsächlich so dort wird
eine zunehmende aktivität beobachtet
zitat
wir glauben dass wir einen erwachenden
vulkan beobachten so der sektionsleiter
der erdbeben-und vulkan physik vom
zentrum in potsdam potsdam
zuvor musste im ego becken dort fühlt
sich wohl ein maresa war und noch etwas
kommt dazu wie in der eifel globale co2
auf dem boden in rund 50 kilometern
tiefe setzt heißes magma dieses gas frei
das ist schon mal klar
noch heißt das gar nichts und trotzdem
wollen die forscher und forscherinnen
der region näher untersuchen denn nach
geologischer zeitrechnung erst vor
300.000 jahren sind dort zwei vulkane
aktiv gewesen kabul und eisen bilden
jetzt will ein internationales
forschungsteam der gefahr auf den grund
gehen im wahrsten sinne des wortes ganz
tief bohren und die frage klären ist
dort eine mark mark kamera die zu einem
vulkanausbruch führt oder nicht bis in
4000 meter tiefe will das team bohren
damit soll geklärt werden ob und wann
dort ein vulkan ausbrechen könnte in 30
jahren könnte es schon so weit sein dorf
sagt im fokus man sollte unbedingt die
chancen für eine region sehen ob sie
vulkan tourismus als chance das würde
auf jeden fall mitteleuropa ziemlich
verändern wenn hier vor unserer nase
vulkane ausbrechen würden ja aber wenn
man sich die eifel anschaut ist das gar
nicht so absurd immerhin wurde er wegen
der erdbebengefahr ausgelöst durch den
vulkanismus das kernkraftwerk mülheim
kärlich wieder stillgelegt ein vulkan in
deutschland unwahrscheinlich wohl nicht
wir halten euch hier auf dem laufenden
klicks und gibt es jetzt übrigens auch
auf englisch wenn ihr freuen darf die
englisch sprechen oder mit mir besser
englisch sprechen lernen wollt dann
abonniert den kanal das geht hier am
besten einfach draufklicken jede woche
drei videos und darunter geht es weiter
mit ice age im euroville begann stream
come to install bis dann bleib dran